the big political story over the last 24
hours Bernie Sanders has suspended his
2020 Democratic presidential campaign
there's just so much to talk about and I
received hundreds of messages since
yesterday about this emails tweets all
sorts of other messages Instagram and so
I want to go through this in sections I
want to make sure we cover everything I
want to make sure we sort of turn over
every stone that needs to be turned over
in thinking about this and and going
forward and so we're going to talk about
Bernie's decision itself and whether it
made sense we'll talk about what exactly
happened in the campaign that at one
point seemed to be going so well we'll
talk about what this means for the
progressive movement and for the future
of who the individuals are that may be
leading that movement we'll talk
eventually we also have to talk about
what this means for November of 2020 so
we're going to get to all of those
things now my concerns from the messages
I've received are centered around I
guess generally that a lot of these
different issues I mentioned are being
mixed up for example there are people
mixing up questions about the future of
the movement with November of 2020 when
there is overlap but really there are
different decisions in different
considerations to be made there and it's
leading to some unclear thinking and
people that I think are not thinking and
in the clearest terms about this and I
want to make sure that if if nothing
else we can disagree about where we end
up but let's make sure we have all of
the facts and that we're thinking
clearly and discretely about all of
these issues if we come to different
conclusions that's fine I have no
problem we're adults but let's think
through the different elements of this
first of all here is Bernie himself
saying it yesterday that he is
suspending his campaign I wish I could
give you better news but I think you
know the truth and that is that we
announced some 300 delegates behind Vice
President Biden and the path toward
victory is virtually impossible so while
we are winning the ideological battle
and while we are winning the support of
so many young people and
working people throughout the country I
have concluded that this battle for the
Democratic nomination will not be
successful and so today I am announcing
the suspension of my campaign so first
of all was this the correct decision for
Bernie Sanders to make the answer is yes
now Bernie talks about the math and he
realizes he says that he has no path to
the nomination it's important to
understand that it's been weeks since
the numbers changed so if the numbers
yesterday show no path to the nomination
he also had no path weeks ago when we
outlined that and still many people were
reacting very emotionally and sort of
resisting that after Super Tuesday
Bernie's shot was diminished to about a
1% shot after the March 10th states
voted he had about a point five percent
chance after March 17th it was smaller
than a point one percent chance and that
has not since changed so Bernie's
decision is the right one Bernie's
decision is backed by the math and
there's no question about that
whatsoever remember even after it was
just Biden versus Bernie and everyone
else was out Biden kept building bigger
and bigger leads in the polls there was
the idea that coronavirus would turn it
around and reinvigorate Bernie's
campaign in the polls
Biden kept pulling away so that's that I
don't really think there's that much
more to say about it
particularly because Bernie has
suspended his campaign next question is
about the timing
Bernie getting out yesterday April 8th
as opposed to earlier as opposed to
later I don't know that this is the most
important issue but I'm not so sure
about the timing I mean to me again the
numbers haven't changed for three weeks
so in a sense it might have made more
sense to get out three weeks ago when we
were not in the middle of the peak of a
hundred year pandemic where this is
likely to get it be a story that gets 24
to 36 hours of attention and then the
attention is going to be greatly
diminished waiting I mean listen if
you've waited this long
maybe you just keep way
with no other primaries that are voting
in person in the immediate maybe you
keep waiting with the idea that when the
virus starts to settle down in the news
as hopefully it will in the next month
although we don't know maybe there's an
opportunity for Bernie to get more
attention with this get some concessions
or something with Joe Biden that will be
a show of both unity and maybe also some
policy concessions that Joe Biden I
don't know I'm thinking out loud here
but I don't think this is really the
most important thing my instinct is that
this is acutely a time because we are
you know 2,000 people a day in the US
are dying right now because of the
corona virus this maybe is not the best
time to get the most attention for what
you're doing and maybe spend the
political capital you've built in the
most effective way but I don't think
it's the most important thing to be
talking about could maybe Bernie get
something out of this in the future
because remember bernie is suspending
you can still vote for him in upcoming
primaries he will continue to accumulate
delegates and at some point in the
future we imagine before or at the
convention the convention may be in
person it may be digital we just don't
know right now because of the virus
maybe there is some show made out of
Bernie turning over his delegates
directing his delegates releasing his
delegates and sending them to Biden in
exchange for something that may still
happen I don't know that we need to
armchair quarterback that too too much
now let's move on to a bigger issue what
about the meaning of this for the
progressive movement and the
understanding of why Bernie lost which
if we don't learn anything from this
it's been a waste we if if we don't
learn anything from this the same things
are going to keep happening now a lot of
this analysis I've done before because
we've already done our post-mortem on
the Bernie campaign mathematically in
the last three weeks nothing changed and
Bernie accepting that the math has no
path to his nomination the math was the
same three weeks ago so we did most of
our postmortem three weeks ago
I won't go crazy spending time on that
but the key points to hit just so we're
all kind of up to speed first of all the
Democratic primary electorate is not as
progressed
as the Internet reddit Twitter
progressive movement might make us think
that it is this is just a reality we
talked about this a few weeks ago there
are a lot of Democratic primary voters
who just aren't participating in those
online forums so we don't see them we
come away thinking that what we see on
Reddit and Twitter is far more
representative of the Democratic primary
electorate than it actually is
we sometimes are swayed by Bernie's
large rallies just because people are
able to gather larger rallies doesn't
necessarily mean they're going to gather
more voters when it actually becomes
time to vote now you will hear on
Twitter in response to this you're wrong
David
everybody wants Medicare for all
everybody wants free college people were
confused or tricked or bamboozled into
voting for Biden because of these wrong
calculations about electability people
are wrong the the theme online is in the
online left it's Bernie is the the the
guy with the popular policies but people
wrongly thought Biden was more electable
so they voted for Biden that's not
really true and if you look at more
detailed polls you know it's very easy
to say everybody loves Medicare for all
but somehow they voted for Biden you
know it's not completely true and this
is something if we don't accept if we
don't realize it we're not going to fix
the problems if you look at data from
the Kaiser Family Foundation it's pretty
clear cavity I want to disclaimer
Kaiser Family Foundation has nothing to
do with Kaiser Permanente the insurance
company sometimes when I mentioned the
kff people say David you're touting
industry talking points no the Kaiser
Family Foundation you can look up google
it it's widely documented it shares the
word Kaiser it has nothing to do with
the insurance company Kaiser Permanente
they're an independent research agency
and the point is the more you tell
people about medicare-for-all and how it
would actually work the lower support is
now this doesn't mean medicare for all
is good or bad I'm talking about the
political viability we have some of the
data on the screen this is not anything
about my opinion it is simply me
reminding you the numbers are more calm
than simply saying everybody loves
medicare-for-all but somehow Biden won
by two and a half million votes the more
you tell people about the specifics of
how medicare-for-all would work the more
divided opinion is it's not
overwhelmingly against Medicare for all
but opinion about Medicare for all is
split very evenly as people learn more
about the specifics so it's not
overwhelming support number two policy
aside not enough people like Bernie
enough to vote for him this is not the
Hillary stuff nobody likes Bernie that
was referring to members of Congress in
the Senate what I'm talking about is
there are lots of people who I'm sure
find Bernie's policies fine but they
didn't like him or his campaign enough
to get them over the hump casting a
ballot for Bernie Sanders now there are
all of these hot takes that Bernie lost
because voters were confused about
issues versus electability but a lot of
people just didn't like Bernie enough to
vote for him it's just the reality okay
I don't take it personally it has
nothing to do with the viability of the
policies either number three I've
already talked about the toxic people
around Bernie there are lots of them
this isn't about mean people on Twitter
that's not what I'm talking about I'm
talking about campaign surrogates it
wouldn't be particularly particularly
decorous for me to start naming them is
it decorous - decorous for me to start
naming them doubt now it's over but
there are lots of people around Bernie
that were repellent to many many voters
it was a bad calculation what can you do
okay what we learned and lastly Bernie
was not helped by some of the optics
around his campaign the democratic
socialist label didn't help I said this
five years ago and there are now more
and more leftist of folks who are coming
around to this it just didn't help
thinking about it's not anything
personal personal personal about Bernie
necessarily but the DEM socialist
language the language of revolution most
Democrats don't want revolution they
want to fix the system and even you know
this is so minor but like when Bernie
praised Cuba's literacy program and then
doubled down on it I get it just because
Cuba did something doesn't mean that
Fidel Castro is good but it just didn't
help Bernie none of this stuff helped
Bernie Sanders all together many factors
so then we get to does this say anything
about the future of the progressive
movement more broadly I think the answer
is not necessarily it depends on the
choices that we make I've said before
the movement to succeed is going to be
need to be led by someone who shares
Bernie's fundamental values but has
better optics better framing better
language and a less toxic supporting
cast around them there's plenty of time
to figure that out we don't want to take
too much time because we want to make
progress and win but there's plenty of
time to figure that out
but in the immediate in the midst of a
hundred year pandemic during which the
president we have is an incompetent
weaponized buffoon we've got to deal
with the general election this is not
trivial this is not academic and this is
where the black white hot takes are just
exploding on the internet probably to
the detriment of the movement bigger
picture because everybody is claiming to
have the perspective that informs what
every Bernie supporter should do in
November you've got the never Biden
people you've got the Bernie or bust
people which are not necessarily the
same as the never Biden people you have
the reluctant sort of trumps better than
Biden but I hate him anyway
people here's my suggestion
let's stop let's be adults here and I'll
explain to you what I mean by that
Bernie supporters have a limited number
of options it's not there's not an
unlimited number of paths forward and
those are you vote for Biden you vote
for Trump you don't vote at all you
write Bernie in talking in November now
you write someone else in or you vote
for a third party candidate these are
all different actions but in practical
terms any of these actions other than
voting Biden is an action that gets
Trump one vote closer to re-election
that's not a value judgment I'm not
saying it's good or bad we'll get to the
values in a moment but any decision
other than a vote for Biden is a
or a non-vote that helps Donald Trump
now you know in blue states were Biden
will win maybe in practice it it matters
less what you do in terms of helping
Trump but at the national level all
choices other than voting Biden are a
vote that helps Trump get closer to
re-election now people may have
different reasons for choosing these
options so as an example you might be a
Bernie supporter and you might choose to
vote for Trump because you actually
preferred Trump to Biden like on policy
I guess it's conceivable you could look
at the policy and you could look at
everything about them the people around
them cabinets that they would okay and
you say I prefer Trump to Biden that's
one reason someone might vote for Trump
over Biden you might be a Bernie
supporter and you might vote for Trump
because you see Trump's re-election as
acceleration astaire to a Biden win and
now acceleration ISM is the idea that
you should accelerate capitalism because
it will speed up its eventual failure
which will bring about the destruction
of capitalism that's an idea you might
choose any of these options other than
voting Biden because you want to teach
the DNC a lesson and you see not voting
for Biden as teaching the D&C a lesson
that you know your vote is not a blank
check so here's where I come down on
this I cannot in good conscience take
any action that will make Trump's
reelection more likely it's very simple
for me I believe that Trump is that bad
I believe the corona virus epidemic has
been sort of the straw that broke the
camel's back or the cherry on top or
whatever metaphor you want to use that
proves beyond any doubt how weaponized
Trump's ignorant and personality
disorders and bad ideas and a cast of
supporters and staffers are this is not
vote blue no matter who for me I have a
video about this on youtube you can
check out I've looked at the options and
I am choosing Biden over Trump because
he's better okay yesterday on Twitter
our friend Kyle kolinsky responded to
journalist Mehdi Hassan's tweet about
the lesser of two evils and Kyle said Oh
okay white nationalist Richard Spencer
versus white nationalist David Duke who
y'all got and I responded half joking
but half serious I guess David Duke he
seems more frail and his supporters
aren't as good at using the internet to
spread their white nationalism the point
here is I believe in harm reduction I
reject the idea that acceleration ISM
will succeed at toppling the system when
you look at history you see that the big
progressive advances which were you know
in the last hundred and so years the
1910 to 1920 progressive era the New
Deal era and the civil rights era those
were not revolution break the system and
build it back up burn it down and start
over
those were advances working within the
system and improving the system now
there is another group that is talking
about you know Biden needs to earn my
vote
the DNC needs to earn my vote they need
to come and get me and unless they come
and get me unless they make overtures
and come and get me they don't deserve
my vote another debate is is it Bernie
who needs to convince his supporters to
vote for Biden or is it Biden who needs
to convince Bernie supporters to vote
for Biden this entire thing is childish
to me this idea of who comes and gets me
specifically strikes me as both childish
and completely irrelevant I don't care
about these people as people
I don't deify politicians I've expressed
before you know the the deification of
Bernie or Tulsi or Andrew yang or Trump
it's all cultish and I just don't think
these are people that should be deified
or revered in this way they're just
people they're just people they are
flawed people I we don't agree with
everything in their platform's period I
don't care about the cult of personality
around them I don't care about them
coming to get my vote I'm not signing a
blank check I look at policy and Biden
is better I'm not arrogant enough to say
Biden's got to come get my vote I've
looked at Biden versus Trump on health
care Biden's better Biden the best no
Biden's better I've looked at Biden
versus Trump on taxes
biden's better I've looked at Biden
versus Trump on selecting judges Biden's
better I've looked at them on the
environment I've looked at them on
diplomacy I've looked at just about
every issue and Biden is better I'm a
big boy
I don't need Biden to come kowtow to me
or do anything like that to get my votes
I've done the analysis on my own and I
know what the right decision is here I'm
not gonna attack people who are going to
go a different path than I'm going I can
only control what I do and communicate
it to you and everybody's got to make
their own decisions I'm not going to do
ad homonyms
of people choosing a different path than
me or anything like that Trump gets
another four years I'll do what I can to
minimize the damage if Biden wins and
defeats Donald Trump it will be a very
important victory for the United States
and it'll be an underwhelming
milquetoast center-left presidency which
I will work my ass off to ensure is as
progressive as possible by pushing Biden
everybody's got to decide for themselves
are you okay with your actions helping
Trump get reelected maybe the answer is
yes I don't think you're a bad person I
just think you're wrong for me the
answer is no so I'm very confident in
the action that I have to take and it's
voting for Biden over Trump let me know
your thoughts I'm ready I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman we will take a break and be
back right after this one of our
sponsors today is a game called
lawgivers a turn based political
simulation game for PC iOS and Android
if you've ever wanted to start a
political party or run for office or
shape the destiny of our country here's
your chance I've been having a ton of
fun with the game you do get to
experience legislative democracy up
close and the dynamics of the game are
really impressive you make election
promises to your constituents it's up to
you whether you keep those promises when
you're in office all of the laws you
pass affect your country's happiness and
safety health care environment you can
abolish laws that are already in place
you can ratify the Constitution you
decide if you want the government to be
a healthy democracy or authoritarian
tyranny you can be corrupt and take
bribes political assassinations are part
of the game it's not sexually it's a
really good time it doesn't get old
because you'll never play it the same
way twice
this is not some cheesy free-to-play
game it's very clear that a lot of time
went into the development it has very
positive reviews on Steam and in the App
Store's four and a half stars or higher
on all platforms go to david pakman.com
slash game which is where you can watch
the trailer download the game for Steam
iOS and Android
that's david pakman.com slash game